we're not home remember Poland says it
is sending 10 000 troops to its border
with Belarus tensions between Warsaw and
Minsk which is Russia's Ally have been
rising recently Poland says two better
Russian helicopters briefly entered its
airspace last week the government is
also concerned about the Border area
since hundreds of Wagner mercenaries
arrived in Belarus as part of a deal
that ended a mutiny in Russia in June
Al Osama bin shafat joins us now from
Poland's border with Belarus and the
focus continues to be on all susceptible
border areas and that includes the build
up of troops Where You Are
well this has been ratcheting up for the
last few days ever since Poland
announced that it is going to be sending
Not Just 2 000 but 10 000 troops to
supplement the Border guard on its
border a fence border with Belarus which
already has a poor defense motion
sensors and cameras because as you
mentioned it not only just fears illegal
migration but it also is afraid that
there might be some Wagner mercenaries
who might try and sneak in it is also to
make sure that those alleged border
incursions which Belarus denies Poland
says happen do not happen again and is
there
an appropriate response from the Polish
side as well so as we're hearing from
the Polish government about how it is
building up we've heard from the
Belarusian side for the first time today
the president Alexander lekshenko
telling his prime minister to establish
contact with the polls saying that
they're ready for talks and negotiations
to uh diffuse tensions only if the poles
are ready to do so themselves so it is
interesting that all of this is
happening as the border between Ukraine
and Russia becomes a grinding place for
both armies no real events taking uh
movement taking place there uh this
seems to be the Border where Poland says
that it is fighting for NATO's war and
making sure that NATO's border is
protected against Russia and its allies
Tower locals where you are reacting to
what's happening in their neighborhood
have you been speaking to people we've
been Crossing through Villages along
this border 187 kilometers long border
and people are concerned they're scared
they're seeing this as a repeat of what
happened a year and a half ago when the
war started between Ukraine and Russia
and businesses are also hurting as well
we spoke to a hotel owner who told us
that people have canceled their holidays
people who come to this picturesque part
of Poland are no longer coming because
they think that things could escalate
further according to analysts we've
spoken to this might be another war of
words between these two neighbors as it
is election season in Poland but people
here on the border region are really
already feeling the impact okay thank
you so much for that that's Osama bin
Javed on Poland's bowler Poland's border
with Belarus